hey guys it's correct I woke up in the
morning to go take a pee pee break to
discover the two trailers dropped I just
watched the power Enders one now the
second trailer for Logan just as a heads
up my speakers aren't working out I was
watching the Power Rangers trailer so
what
I need the girl baccarat Oh
now bamboos way down we go we got the f
words
the weather songs and trails
you should take a moment
yes this loves a Wolverine kick-ass
that's be cool shot the F words in this
trailer we got the Fox
we got the [__] I said it you know like
in a video in 2016 that Logan is my most
anticipated movie of 2017 and it's just
further amplifies that feeling I love
the opening of this trailer where x-23
is robbing the store flips that guy over
because you know you do get that quality
in there you get actually a little bit
of Units one thing I messed with the
power and sure looking sure you get some
humor in these trailers and in this
Logan trailer you know having Logan have
had more that fatherly quality over her
having to discipline know that that kind
of attitude I thought that was really
fun to watch they know we're gonna see
Logan's daddy characteristics in here
I'm beginning to get a bigger sense of
the plot here this trailer does make it
more define it is very much in team with
the synopsis that Hugh Jackman released
about you know Professor axe and Logan
they're hiding out in Mexico or on the
Mexican border I believe until this
young girl x-23 comes into their lives a
lot of its gonna center around X 23 and
X 23 looks freaking sweet I heard they
should like 40 minutes of this movie at
a screening which by the way I just
think it's way too long I don't think
you should be showing 40 minutes of a
film it's like a good chunk of the movie
at that point 20-minute screening I was
already like that's a lot but I could
got again I'm more of a 20 minutes a 40
minutes it's like wait wait one thing
that people were saying when they were
when they left the 40 minute screening
was that X 23 is a major standout and
it's like a major highlight at the film
and just looking at the footage here she
looks like she kicks ass little girls
kicking ass looks great you know I think
of liking kick-ass when Hit Girl was
kicking ass she was a bad
little girl this looks like another
badass little girl her own in their own
unique way because when she's like being
a little girl and smiling and stuff she
seems just really adorable but when she
has like that look of like medicine
don't [__] with me in her eyes it's
intimidating I love how the first
trailer had Johnny Cash's hurt over it I
love that this has the K leo song way
down we go on it cuz I love both those
artists and makayley oh I've been
listening to a lot of K leo lately
they're they're probably my new favorite
band
I'm sure the COS james mangold is very
particular about a soundtrack so I'm
hoping that this movie has some awesome
music like those two songs the action
scenes like when they're when the people
are waiting outside of that warehouse
and then max 23 is [__] them up
Wolverines find them - or when
Wolverines running through you know the
forest or the woods at that point and
then he's like slashing up people there
the action scenes do look really
freaking sweet and this might be the
only time we see Wolverine with the
yellow costume when he's flipping
through the pages of the x-men comics I
like having that scene where they're
talking about like the mutants the x-men
and who they are
I like that scenes at least the moments
they showed in this trailer because it's
really established and this is gonna be
totally a different world that was like
the x-men in movies and all that that's
still part of a comic book cartoony kind
of world this one's gonna have a much
more realistic approach it's a fun way
to kind of share the comparison between
all the other x-men films and what this
one's gonna be like then some people
frightened little Deadpool II don't you
think breaking the fourth wall yeah
maybe it does make you wonder if
Deadpool would make a cameo though I
mean I know Ryan Reynolds like totally
debunked that whole thing
I just don't think Deadpool would fit
into this specific movie but who knows I
mean with that kind of referencing maybe
it is there I did play The Last of Us
for three hours so I definitely am seen
the comparison that people are drawing
between the last of us in this movie it
does feel like the last of x-men or
something I feel like this trailer while
it had a different tone more of like
this is gonna be like a more badass have
a little bit more humorous wrinkle than
their I still felt like it did it lose
anything of what the first trailer did
it's not like you know when you see all
these trailers for movies a lot of times
it's like well this just has it seems
totally different than they last trailer
we saw
I think this is a great second trailer
because I don't feel like it loses
everything from the first trailer it's
showing different elements and different
tones and styles that will also be
implemented into this film I thought it
was a great second trailer March can't
come any sooner so what y'all think of
the Logan trailer you excited for this
would be more excited for the Power
Rangers you got to compare them right if
you knew the challenge you can subscribe
today I would really like that now I am
going to go to the bathroom again
because I didn't take my daily morning
number two and then I'm going to
possibly go back to sleep for the rest
of the day and then throw my house sleep
cycle off